[Music]
Hey it's me, Destin.
So uh, welcome to my 4th of July tradition.
It's something I do every year. I'm
out here on the Bickering Nag,
alone, this year.
Everybody else had something they had to do
because the firework show is late.
But anyway, I'm just gonna kind
of take you into my tradition,
show you what I do.
We always try to stay close to the bank,
because we don't want to get
near the motorized vehicles.
This is kind of weird; makes you
think the Booger's gonna get you.
But anyway, um... So
what we do is we set up
opposite from the firework
show, on the river.
I take time-lapse, open
shutter photography,
and I've always been notoriously
bad at chemistry. Like, real bad.
So this year I decided I was
going to learn the chemicals
and the different colors that
they make for fireworks.
so I researched it a little bit, so I'm
going to run through that with you.
These are, uh... not pure
elements that we're burning here.
These are compounds created with these
elements, so keep that in mind.
Red is strontium.
Orange is calcium. Calcium salts, usually.
Uh, electric white's like magnesium
or aluminium, or something like that.
Um...
Blue, that was a pretty good one.
Blue is usually copper.
Green is barium.
Yellow is sodium compounds.
Gold is some type of iron, usually
with some kind of potash,
or some kind of carbon in it.
Purple is a combination
of strontium and copper,
so you get the red and
the blue going together.
[Bangs]
But anyway, I hope you enjoyed my pictures.
I hope you think it's pretty cool.
I really like it. It's uh...
one of my favorite traditions,
and I do it every year.
Unfortunately, the kids
had to go to bed early
because this year the
firework show was too late.
They really enjoy this. It's
one of their favorite things,
and I miss my wife out here
with me this year as well.
But anyway, you are getting
smarter every day,
and tell your friends.
Have a good one. Bye.
[Music]
...and where your relative motion is
going, so you can compensate for it.
Well, chickens are really
good at this, so...
I'll show you. Watch his
head stay totally stationary
as I move his body. I can move his
body in pretty much any direction.
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.